also wahrscheinlich ging es ja jedem
unserer zuschauer soeben im studio so
wenn man heute an die preisschilder
geguckt hat bei tankstellen hier sehen
was ja waren enorme preise zu sehen
immerhin
2,2 eur 35 habe ich irgendwo gesehen der
durchschnitt für einen liter e10 war bei
zwei euro und einem cent unglaublich
noch vor wenigen wochen hätte man
gedacht es kommt nie und wenn es kommt
dann haben uns die politiker lindner
wissing verkehrsminister lindner
finanzminister jetzt olaf scholz kanzler
jetzt da waren sie all das noch nicht in
ihren ämtern da war noch wahlkampf da
haben sie uns alle versprochen das kommt
auf keinen fall dann können sie sich auf
uns verlassen also benzin darf nicht zum
luxusgut werden nein nein wir können auf
keinen fall familien in die pleite
treiben wir können auf keinen fall zur
armut beitragen wir müssen die mobilität
hochhalten all das es versprochen worden
und jetzt sagt nach der wahl lernen wir
in einem konkreten sachverhalt
versprochen ist versprochen und wird
halt dann doch gebrochen also das ist
etwas was ein jahr schon ein bisschen
emotionalisiert und es wird noch
schlimmer wenn man sich christian
lindner jetzt anhört jetzt zieht er
nämlich durchs land und sagt er könne
die mehrwertsteuer auf benzin gar nicht
senken weil das insgesamt ja sozusagen
gar nicht zu einer wirklichen entlastung
beitragen würde und dann kommt ein meine
worte dafür sind technisches geschrieben
das ist ziemlich dreist weil er könnte
es natürlich er könnte es sofort er
könnte es morgen verkünden und anordnen
aber er will nicht und warum will er
nicht weil er ganz kräftig daran
mitverdient an jedem cent den das benzin
teurer wird verdient der staat wieder
mit der finanzminister auch und jetzt
kommt das aller allerbeste
das ist ja gar nicht sein geld was er da
einnimmt sondern unseres und deshalb
glaube ich dass die stunde gekommen ist
wo ganz konkret der bundesfinanzminister
an die seite der bürger treten muss
deren geld er verwaltet und für sie
agieren muss und nicht gegen sie und in
letzter zeit ist mir aufgefallen bezieht
sich christian lindner immer häufiger
auf seinen amtseid dem wohle des volkes
dienen zu müssen das stimmt dem wohl des
volkes verdienen heißt aber nicht nur
ein krieg vermeiden sondern auch
vermeiden dass familien pleite gehen und
deshalb ist ganz klar die stunde
christian lindner zuzurufen herr
finanzminister
senken sie die mehrwertsteuer auf benzin
und zwar dramatisch ich würde
vorschlagen von 19 auf 7 prozent und
zwar sofort
frauen brauchen wirklich spritpreis
bremser für die bürger absolut
fertig ja da also düssel ja wirklich
besser klein erklärung kam gerade von
studien und ich denke mir irgendwie das
also ich kann sie verstehen dass man
jetzt darüber diskutiert ich habe auch
eingesehen in der sendung hier gestern
oder so was war da braucht er das im
grundgesetz verankert er kann es nicht
machen verstehe ich gar nichts von war
ich kenne das grundgesetzlich auswendig
und weiß nicht in welchem paragrafen
dasteht ich kann es auch nicht checken
gegenchecken in dem moment dann will er
nicht schulden machen bei unseren enkeln
et cetera für mich und ich bin
eigentlich ein christian lindner fan
muss ich sagen ich mochte den immer sehr
und ich fand daneben war sehr
sympathisch der doch immer sehr gut
gesprochen ich habe ihn verstanden das
reicht mir meistens bei der politik
nichts desto trotz fand ich in dem
moment dachte ich so nee das reicht mir
nicht wenn man muss ehrlich sein er
verwendet ein argument über das man eine
sekunde nachdenken muss er sagt ja das
würde im prinzip wenig bringen wenn er
das täte weil die menschen die jetzt
mehr geld für benzin ausgeben woran der
mehr verdient geben dieses geld ja für
andere dinge nicht aus deswegen verdient
da gar nicht wirklich mehr sondern da
verliert er sogar einnahmen und wenn man
dann mal kurz darüber nachdenken stellt
man fest der lindner das stimmt aber es
setzt irgendwie ein falsches paradigma
voraus nämlich dass der staat immer
genauso viel geld einnehmen muss man
könnte er in einer krisenzeit auch mal
sagen man gibt es zurück man hat nicht
mehr so viel geld wie vorher sondern man
gibt es zurück und wenn ich mir überlege
was wir alles in zukunft bezahlen müssen
also
300 milliarden corona und das ist nur
der anfang gewesen
100 milliarden
verteidigungsausgaben
damit jetzt schon der eindruck erweckt
das ist halt jetzt geld sondervermögen
lindner sagt immer das leid man sich aus
der zukunft also das heißt dass alles so
indirekt die wahrheit ist ja dass
irgendwann zahltag sein wird und jeder
von uns kann jetzt schon mal fünf
prozent seines haushalts netto zur seite
legen für das was dann über steuern über
abgaben über irgendwelches so ließ über
sonst was auf uns zukommen wird und in
einer solchen situation wie jetzt wo
menschen schon durch eine inflation von
5% und diese sorge was kommt da in der
zukunft noch auf mich zu sowieso schon
finanziell angespannt sind müsste der
staat eigentlich sagen zu unserer
haushalterischen verantwortung gehört
jetzt beim benzin zu sagen wir geben was
zurück bzw wir nehmen es nicht noch mehr
ein denn das muss man schon mal sagen
alles was jetzt teure 10 cent teurer
bedeutet auch viele viele cent für den
staat mehr und die wenigstens die
wenigstens soll nicht zusätzlich
einnehmen sonst hat man nämlich das
gefühl er bereichert sich irgendwie in
der situation die wir jetzt haben ich
finde auch etwas was ich mich aber war
der moment eine sekunde nachlassen ist
ja da aus dem oft fast schon paulianer
nicht gehört ich habe freiwillig und
habe da ich wollte ich wollte ich wollte
frau würde ich gar nicht unterbrechen
ich denke wir haben nur ein bild hoch
bei dieser debatte um die benzinpreise
und ich stelle mich ich stelle mir die
frage in diesen tagen wie sehr das das
mag zwar populistisch klingen aber
politiker tatsächlich noch
nachvollziehen können denn heute gab es
ein video von tobias hans den
ministerpräsidenten vom saarland der 111
video gemacht hat und das erstaunliche
war nicht dasselbe video und die
litfaßsäule sondern dass man im
hintergrund seine dienstlimousine
gesehen hat also nicht nur seine sondern
auch die der sicherheit und da fragt man
sich natürlich wie nah sind solche
politiker dann noch bei den menschen
tatsächlich und tanken sie tatsächlich
noch selbst das gleiche habe ich mal im
wahlkampf langes hervor der ukraine
krieg und vielen anderen dingen ich
glaube im juni war es
scholz gefragt den damaligen
kanzlerkandidaten von dem damals noch
jeder gesagt hatte er würde niemals
kanzler werden und als ich ihm diese
frage gestellt habe ob er denn wisse wie
hoch der benzinpreis ist da musste er
sagen will das weiß er nicht und das
liege auch daran dass er eigentlich gar
nicht mehr selbst krank weil er hat ja
sicherheit und die sicherheit tankt ja
also wie sehr in diesem kosmos berlin
sind überhaupt die politiker noch
imstande zu realisieren was die
tankfüllung für die gesamte familie
bedeutet ja die rächen denn ist
wahrscheinlich eher in schnipseln
beuchert um das ist das edle restaurant
hier und sagen na ja gott dann ist halt
so
ich habe aber nur ein anderer punkt der
mich beschleicht also pauls gedanke dass
die politiker möglicherweise gar nicht
mehr in der wirklichkeit verankert sind
ist reizvoll und stimmt auch glaube ich
habe noch einen anderen gedanken wer
mich beschleicht der ist fast ein
bisschen tabulos in diesen tagen des
krieges wir haben natürlich zwei
regierungsparteien denen es gefällt dass
der spritpreis steigt die spd und die
grünen weil mit steigendem spritpreis
und dem leid der menschen was ich jetzt
sozusagen dieses lamentieren der leute
über spritpreis heißt ja immer auch naja
hättest den lastenfahrrad dann bräuchte
es da auch kein benzin hättest du im
auto dann bräuchte es da auch kein
benzin würdest du mehr zu fuß gehen dann
läuft es da auch kein benzin
wir vertrauen euch so wie es euch auto
fahren sowieso gerade alle innenstädte
mit allen möglichen radwegen die kreuz
und quer gehen worüber man sich aufregen
kann also das volk schon auch einer
gewissen logik und es könnte sein dass
der von dieser dort bewunderte christian
lindner der auch einsteiger 100 habe ich
nicht gefährdet
aus sicht
von deere fendt
der ja auch ein
potente politiker ist in dieser
konstellation
möglicherweise gar nicht anders kann als
zu sagen die benzinpreise sind mein
kleinstes problem ich habe ganz andere
und das schimmert alles durch durch
diesen eigentlich unvorstellbaren
tatbestand dass politik was zugunsten
der bürger ändern könnte aber es einfach
nicht macht ja aber jetzt mal ganz im
ernst kann man wirklich davon ausgehen
jetzt ernsthaft gesprochen dass ein
politiker der bundeskanzler von
deutschland da sehr normales leben gibt
das können doch jetzt auch nicht
unterstellen man kann jetzt sagen die
sind realitätsfern natürlich sind die
realitätsferne dass der bundeskanzler
den schädiger nicht das land mit streiks
war deshalb so schön weil wir eben am
nächsten tag vorgerechnet haben an wie
viele tankstellen er von seinem amtssitz
bis zu seiner wohnung vorbeifährt und
der einfach nur aus dem fenster schauen
müsste um den benzinpreis herauszufinden
ich glaube da ist was dran das ist ein
leben das nicht versteht die
grundaussage und die kernaussagen da
gebe ich will noch eins sein wird aber
seinen niedrigen essen dürfen politiker
ist dass sie ja quasi nicht einfach so
für sich da sind sondern sie sind von
uns gewählt damit sie unsere interessen
vertreten und es gibt kein interesse an
einem durch die decke explodierende
benzinpreis von niemanden außer lass
mich nachdenken der finanzminister wie
gesagt krieg mehr und das mich auch
aufregt und was auch ein bisschen wenig
diskutiert wird ist noch ist der ölpreis
ja gar nicht so viel höher also das
höher als vor ein paar wochen aber das
was jetzt in dem preis drin steckt der
chinesen seit 2000 ja ja aber er ist
noch nicht so hoch wie diese breitet
sich ua ist aber noch nicht so hoch wie
der benzinpreis worauf sich aus will ist
die mineralölfirmen antizipieren
natürlich was kommen wird und hauen es
jetzt schon auf den preis das heißt auch
shell aral wie sie alle heißen machen
sich in der zwischenzeit natürlich die
taschen voll und das finde ich ist
mindestens so interessant zu
durchleuchten wie die forderung die
mehrwertsteuer zu senken stell mir dann
auch als letzte frage zu diesem thema
die frage ein herr ischinger hersteller
werben sind selber hier schon debattiert
wie nah sind die politiker dennoch am
alltag der menschen dran gibt es dort
handlungs und wie oft danken sie selber
also wissen sie ich habe ja in meiner
diplomatischen zwei
seiten iss verbracht in washington in
sondern wenn ich das so vergleiche
miteinander dann muss ich jetzt noch
eine gewisse ehrenerklärung für die
deutsche
politikerriege abgeben ich glaube die
sind relativ betrachtet doch noch weit
näher an ihren mitbürgern an ihren
wahlkreisen als die total zum teil total
abgerufen den britischen politiker also
ich denke jetzt nicht nur an die person
war ist sonst auch so manchem im house
of lords ich denke an amerikanischer
politiker senatoren die die vollkommen
die fassung und die die die bodenhaftung
verloren haben denkt sie an die an die
tramper und ich denke auch an so manchen
in frankreich also erscheint mir das
größte problem deutschlands nicht
hinzulegen glaube der durchschnittliche
bund deutsche bundestagsabgeordnete am
mittag staatssekretär und minister der
ist eigentlich noch relativ nahe an den
bürgern an und das ist ganz gut so